DISTRICTS.
AND TONIGHT IT'S WHATEVER
HAPPENED TO SEGMENT, DEMOCRACY
VOUCHERS, REMEMBER THEM?
IT WAS THE CITY OF SEATTLE'S
ATTEMPT TO BRING MORE PEOPLE
INTO THE PROCESS OF PAYING FOR A
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN.
BUT IT CAME WITH SOME UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES.
CORRESPONDENT DAN SPRINGER TELLS
US WHAT HAPPENED.
>> WHEN WE FIRST REPORTED LAST
JULY ON SEATTLE'S NOVEL
EXPERIMENT TO PUBLICLY FINANCED
MUNICIPAL ELECTIONS BY GIVING
REGISTERED VOTERS 25 VOUCHERS TO
GIVE TO THEIR FAVORITE
CANDIDATE, THE CANDIDATES WERE
SCRAMBLING TO QUALIFY FOR THE
DEMOCRACY VOUCHERS.
THE PROGRAM TAXES PROPERTY
OWNERS IN AN EFFORT TO REDUCE
THE INFLUENCE OF MONEY ON LOCAL
POLITICS.
BUT ACCORDING TO THE SEATTLE
ETHICS AND ELECTION COMMITTEE
SPENDING ONLY INCREASE, WITH
THOSE WHO SPEND THE MOST WINNING
EVERY TIME.
>> YOU CAN RATCHET DOWN CAMPAIGN
SPENDING LIMITS, YOU CAN RATCHET
DOWN CONTRIBUTION LIMITS, BUT
MONEY WILL FIND ITS WAY.
>> THE NEW SYSTEM SPAWNED A
WHOLE NEW WAY TO CHEAT, SHELLY
SECREST WHO RAN UNSUCCESSFULLY
FOR CITY COUNCIL HAS BEEN
CHARGED WITH FRAUD AND
THEFT.
HER CAMPAIGN MANAGER TIPPED OFF
POLICE THAT SHE USED HER OWN
MONEY TO MAKE IT LOOK SHE
HAD ENOUGH SMALL DONATIONS TO
QUALIFY FOR THE VOUCHERS.
>> IF SOMEONE IS GOING TO GO
AGAINST THE RULES COME I THINK
THAT THEY SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> CRITICS ALSO SAY THAT THE
VOUCHERS KEEP THE STATUS QUO AND
EVEN THE SEATTLE POLITICS
FURTHER LEFT.
JOHN GRANT WORKED THE SYSTEM TO
PERFECTION.
RELYING ON A SMALL ARMY OF
VOLUNTEERS CULTIVATED AT THE
RENTERS UNION WHICH HE RAN TO
COLLECT THE MAXIMUM NUMBER OF
VOUCHERS.
THE EVENTUAL WINNER ALSO MAXED
OUT ON VOUCHERS AND RECEIVED A
BIG UNIT DONATIONS ON TOP OF
THAT.
FINISHING THIRD JUST OUTSIDE THE
TOP TWO RUNOFF WITH A LITTLE BIT
MORE FROM SARA NELSON.
>> IT PROPPED UP THE INCUMBENT
AND TO THE, AND THE PEOPLE WITH
VOLUNTEERS WITH CLIPBOARDS.
>> BUT SUPPORTERS SAY THAT THE
VOUCHERS WERE A SUCCESS.
GIVEN SOME POLITICAL CLOUT TO
EVEN THE POOREST AND MAKE
CANDIDATES TAKE NOTICE.
>> WE DID SEE CAMPAIGN IN THE
WAY THAT WE HAVE NOT IN THE
PAST.
NOT SITTING IN A CONFERENCE ROOM
DIALING FOR DOLLARS, BUT OUT
POUNDING THE PAVEMENT.
TO SPEAK OF THE PROGRAM IS VERY
EXPENSIVE, CANDIDATES RECEIVE
$1.1 MILLION IN VOUCHER MONEY,
BUT IT COST OVER A MILLION DOLLA
BUT IT COST OVER A MILLION DOLLS
BUT IT COST OVER A MILLION DOLLT
BUT IT COST OVER A MILLION DOLLO
RUN.
A HIGH SUM FOR A SYSTEM THAT DID
CREATE MANY MORE CAMPAIGN
DONORS, BUT BY THE CITY'S OWN